c'est en france le centre national du
cinéma qui délivre les autorisations de
diffusion des films
jérôme clément bonsoir vous en êtes pas
le président 22 ans donc pour autoriser
la diffusion à tous les publics de ce
film c'est trop ou ce n'est pas assez
s'il suffisait simplement calistri
buteur veille ressortir le film et
demandent l'autorisation si elle avait
demandé plus tôt j'imagine que le film
aurait été interdit aurait été à nouveau
autorisée et que l'interdiction aurait
été levée donc c'est simplement à la
discrétion de ceux qui veulent sortir le
film mais quand même le système de
censure a été modifié en france au cours
de ces vingt dernières années
oui il ya eu des réformes successives
qui ont tendu à à libéraliser le régime
il n'y a plus maintenant pratiquement
plus dans les faits d'interdiction tout
public et d'interdiction au total des
films et aussi le système d'interdiction
à l'exportation qui à l'époque avait
défrayé la chronique a été supprimé
maintenant on est revenu une pratique
qui vise essentiellement à protéger à
l'aide de l'essence et l'enfance donc
essentiellement à empêcher que soient
diffusés des films qui touche à la
violence qui touche à la drogue qui
touche à des choses qui peuvent choquer
en particulier les jeunes je crois que
c'est la protection de l'enfance et
l'adolescence qui est le critère majeur
et non plus le critère moral bien
entendu est-ce que là la télévision et
ses excès actuels ne posent pas
difficile problème aux responsables du
cinéma
bah oui tout à fait parce que s'il n'y a
pas du tout d'équivalent à la télévision
est un film qui interdit aux moins de 18
ans par exemple à dans les salles peut
être diffusée à 20h30 il ya donc là une
correction à faire et le crack et des
abus il faudrait sans doute trouver des
correspondances pour que comme l'a
souligné récemment catherine tasca
les films qui sont programmés à 20h30
par exemple soit
autorisée pour tous publics etc on
n'autorise pas à 20h30 des films qui
sont interdits en salle à -18 ans ou
moins de 13 ans je crois que c'est un
des exemples pour trouver les liens
entre les deux systèmes parce
qu'actuellement il n'y en a pas et je
crois que l'objectif qui est
essentiellement de protéger l'enfance et
l'adolescence n'est pas toujours atteint
on peut le regretter
jérôme clément merci c'est une réflexion
qui est encore en tout cas entre les
présidents de chaînes de télévision